yeah I could have watched seventh son
but I didn't because this is what smart
people are doing today the Spongebob
movie sponge out of water the sponge out
of water is another spongebob movie the
last one came out like 10 years ago and
then sponge out of water the recipe -
they're super awesome burger that look
the food that they all ate it disappears
and everyone freaks out the whole town
goes into an apocalypse and now
spongebob and the villain plankton team
up and they have to get it back sounds
like nonsense and it kind of is but
that's kind of the beautiful thing about
this movie
this is a spongebob movie that appeals
to spongebob fans first and foremost and
I get that they made another Simpsons
movie I wouldn't expect them to change
the formula so everyone can get it now
it's like making Simpsons movie for
Simpsons fans what if therefore it's
accessible for people like me like I
haven't seen any spongebob episodes I
haven't seen the Spongebob movie spent
on in the background while I'm doing
other stuff at all in all I'm not like
oh [ __ ] SpongeBob's on earth set the DVR
but I enjoyed this movie I mean it
starts out with an action sequence yes
it's clever funny quips going on I'm
chuckling and we alright yeah I'm
getting this movie and then after that
it goes everywhere it's a fantasy movie
it's a time travel movie it's a
superhero movie it's in everything
moving just a spongebob thing I always
saw spongebob as that movie that
appealed to like the a DD millenials and
it does not give that up
it holds those reins tight it never
actually breaches the most I like How to
Train Your Dragon ruler oh my god there
are moments in there for adults to be
more wiser a couple of moments that are
there for you know teenagers kids
they'll get it adults will still chuckle
and have a good time with the movies not
like they're gonna like put a gun to
their head if they have to watch this
movie with their kids but all in all you
can tell this movie is going for the
kids
I enjoyed the crew in this movie I like
spongebob I like Patrick I liked
everybody there are more than a couple
moments tougher you people out there who
sneak food into the movie theater
because concessions is just too costly
if you sneak brownies into this movie
yeah brownies you're gonna be like oh my
god what hopefully kids don't get the
cut I'm just talking about brownies kids
just normal ones
not anything weird about them nothing
magical I will say the trailer was kind
of false advertisement the trailer I saw
showed him where they were on land and
they were kind of CGI characters and I
thought that was going to be the movie
no you get classic spongebob they're all
animated they're underwater that
old thing where they're on land and
they're CGI characters that was the last
act of the movie so the Spongebob movie
sponge out of water it was energetic it
had momentum it kept going it does what
it sets out to do which is give Sponge
Bob fans a new adventure they're gonna
love it kids'll love it teenagers will
love it adults will be like they'll
enjoy it but it's not there to hit them
where they live the craziness of the
movie might put some people off there
might be like I don't get it here go
back in your box and I will say the
Spongebob movie sponge out of water is a
really good time no alcohol required now
they can make an anime nee X movie ma
all right so the Spongebob movie sponge
out of water have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you wanna see more click right here to
see more